So when we talk about cancer in our office, it's the same thing with any chronic patient.
Any patient we take on our larger plans, there's four pieces that I call pillars that
we have to deal with.
So there's four pillars.
So it's easiest to explain with cancer.
The first pillar is, what is the cause and how are we getting it rid of that?
So when you're dealing with cancer, there's always a cause.
So from a standard oncology approach, that is completely ignored.
Unless you donate your body to science after you died of cancer, and that's what they're
doing with the study on.
For instance, H. Pylore, which is a gram negative bacteria in the same family as Lyme,
Borrelia, is the number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide according to the World Health
Organization based upon numerous studies on the cause of stomach cancer that were funded
by some pharmaceutical company wanting to kill H. Pylore, probably.
But otherwise, it's a completely ignored.
They don't even still, if you had come into the oncologist with stomach cancer, and you
came in and said, doctor, here's a paper from the World Health Organization that says the
number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide is H. Pylore infection, are you going to treat
my H. Pylore infection?
You probably, again, either throw you out of the office or he'll say, yeah, we'll look
at that.
And here's the chemotherapy that we're going to do.
Still, even having that knowledge, they still don't treat the cause.
To understand, to me, it makes no sense.
If you have a cause of cancer, there is a reason why, to understand what cancer is, cancer
is a normal cell that is, for some reason, cause is not going through normal program cell
death, apoptosis.
It is in a state of rapid replication, which in itself is a state of an issue with methylation.
So the idea of how a cell replicates, a cell, every cell in your body will replicate a new
cell, and the mother cell will die.
And that is how your body survives.
You slough off skin cells, because you replicated new skin cells, and the other skin cells died
when they sloughed off.
That's called apoptosis, that's a neuroprogram cell death.
If a cell doesn't go through apoptosis, normal program cell death, and it, for some reason,
is in a hypo-bethylation of the DNA replication cycle, it will be in a state of hyper-replication.
That is, by definition, cancer, that's what cancer is, cells not dying, and hyper-replicating.
Why?
There's an issue, there's a genetic issue, there's a toxicity issue, there's some chemical toxicity,
there's some infection, there's some something is going on, we need to address that piece.
So that's pillar number one, what's the cause and how are we going to get rid of it?
And I believe you can't find out that answer.
Number two is, what are we going to use for a nutraceutical standpoint?
So I'm an alternative cancer doctor, I don't use chemotherapy.
So what are we going to use for a nutritive chemotherapy?
A nutraceutical, something for a nutritional standpoint that's going to specifically affect the cancer itself.
There's lots of things out there.
Are we going to use rick Simpson oil that somebody brought up to me before?
THC?
Are we going to use coxene?
Are we going to use layatrial?
Are we going to use, there's 20, 30 different possible nutraceutical cancer killers out there.
So we test for what that is.
What are we going to use specifically?
That's the second pillar.
What are we going to use for the patient?
So I test using a specialized form of kinesiology.
Thirdly, I use the rife with every cancer patient.
What frequencies are we going to use?
So we decide what frequencies we're going to use for that patient based on scanning them.
And we use the ones that develop that scanner that I think Mike has out here with the electron that you connect to the K-27 point.
And we scan for frequencies.
That's one way I determine what frequencies we're going to use.
There's no frequencies for that specific cancer.
We're going to use that.
We're going to use frequencies to support adjacent organs, and support detoxification pathways, and support the kidneys, and the gut, et cetera.
And we're going to use some other frequencies depending on what I also want to, whatever I have tested is the cause for that cancer.
We're going to help support that.
And some other things that I want to put in the program.
So I personally write every single person's program, and I write date programs.
So they're running the programs while they're sleeping.
So I personally, this is my philosophy.
I don't want my patients right feet all day long.
I want them living.
I mean, what good is it?
Why am I going to stay alive for another five years with this cancer?
And I have to sit in front of the right for sheet all day long.
I want them living.
I want them to go with their job back.
I want them to be a productive member of society.
So that you can write if you can do most of your treatment at night while you're sleeping.
You've got to sleep anyhow.
Yes.
Do I have a generalized favorite detox program I do at night?
No.
I don't.
Sorry.
I don't believe in protocols, okay?
So I want to build a protocol around the patient and their needs.
So, that's the third piece, right feet, using the right.
The fourth piece is a hodgepodge, especially for cancer patients.
We are looking at their genetics.
We're going to look at what diet we're going to put up.
Do they need to be on a low-buttiety diet, a low glutinous diet, a glutinous diet, a low sugar diet?
What do we need to do with that person?
Is diet even driving the cancer at all?
Sometimes it's not.
What do we need to do to support the liver or the gut?
We have to do all the stuff that we talked about today.
It just goes on and on.
Are we going to do coffee in a buzz?
Are we going to?
There's an emotional spiritual side.
We need to support that too.
You can't get out of this terror in your mind.
You're never going to get better.
We have to balance the sympathetics and parasympathetics.
That's the other side of your nervous system, your autonomic nervous system,
that controls all organ function.
So, for persons that are sympathetic, dominant state,
we have to pull that down and balance that and stimulate vagal nerve function.
So, there's a lot of different pieces that are fourth-pillar.
But those are the four pillars that we go through.
It takes two days in our office to really sludge through most of that.
The patient goes home with the right machine.
They start using it every night.
They go home with a three-rigbiter with their program,
and their protocol, and they're following that.
And then as we get the gene information back, we tweak it, we add that,
and we just keep tweaking their program.
And if the patient continues to do well,
it was supposed to be dead three months ago,
and they're doing great.
No, it's six months later, 12 months later.
We just continue on, and that's our goal.
So, I don't believe I cure cancer.
I don't.
I don't believe that anybody cures cancer,
but I do believe that you can manage it,
and turn it into a chronic management disorder
that you can continue to live long after you were not supposed to be alive.
So, that's our goal.
So, that's what we do for patients that come in our office.
Live, it's very similar.
Live, you have to deal with some other things
that you don't have to do with cancer.
Live is more difficult to deal with than cancer.
And I've said, multiple times,
and my line patients give me an enemy.
But I'd rather have a stage 4 cancer patient walk in the door
than a chronic line patient.
Because there, it eases your effects.
You're what?
Easier it affects.
So, with live, you have to deal with a lot of inflammation of the brain.
And that's when you have to build brain pathways.
And that's where, you know, using home brain-based therapy.
And I have a home brain-based therapy manual.
And we send home with patients.
And sometimes it will feed back you,
and that we send home with patients.
All right.
No.
So, a Bikes program uses brain and treatment.
So, let's touch on that a little bit.
What is brain and treatment?
Your brain, from a electrical perspective,
fires at different hearts.
That is cycles per second.
So, when I'm going to fall asleep,
I have to be noted about four to five hertz.
That's an alpha wave.
When I'm like, all excited at a similar,
or listening to Dr. Carter's,
wait a second, everybody's really at four hertz.
You're at about 25 hertz.
A beta wave, a high beta wave, is about 28 hertz.
That's when you're really concentrated.
You're really excited.
You're playing basketball.
You're really concentrated.
You're going to game.
You're excited.
You're at a very high frequency.
And about 28 hertz.
Do you realize you're watching this screen all day?
This is brain and treatment at 60 hertz.
Screens.
All screens.
Television screens.
Telephone screens.
High-pad screens.
Every computer screen type thing is focusing at 60 hertz.
You are trading your brain at 60 hertz.
So, this is another thing we have at 80-80-80-HD child.
They can't use screens.
We limit their screen time.
You can get blocking glasses.
Dark amber sunglasses that will help block some of that.
Note of it's perfect.
You're going to limit screen time.
This is one of our problems in society.
Is it a chemical issue?
Yes.
Is it a disciplined issue?
Maybe.
Is there other, you know, toxicity issues,
vaccine issues, all these things?
Kids are going outside playing anymore.
They're not playing in the dirt, building their immune system,
groaning themselves.
They're in front of screens, watching computers,
playing video games, looking for Pokemon characters.
Is that 60 hertz because of the...
That's just how it's made.
They're all made that way.
Yep.
You are trading your brain at 60 hertz,
and I think you're going to drop down to 4 hertz and go to sleep.
This thing adds to early dimension.
It's very exciting to worry to your brain.
Your feedback is different than brain and treatment.
Your feedback, you're specifically connecting leads to whatever part of the brain
that you're trying to fire connected to a piece of equipment,
connected to a computer.
Yes, you're getting screen time.
It's really doing 20 minutes of it.
And you're actually turning that movie on and off with your brain.
So if I'm connected to my...
My FP1, FP2 right here.
That's firing my prefrontal cortex.
So if I have prefrontal cortex issues,
I can purposely trade my prefrontal cortex.
Or if I have chronic pain issues,
I can purposely trade my parinolope.